Welcome back. We are going to hear from some
viewers and listeners via discord momentarily
at David Pakman dot com slash discord, you can,
of course, get a David Pakman show membership,
which gives you early access to full episodes of
the show so you can hear live calls or avoid them,
depending on your preference much earlier than
anybody else. All right. Very, very exciting
stuff. David Pakman dotcom slash discord is
the place to get in touch with me. Why don't
we go first today? Let's try something different.
Let's go to Johanna in Chile. Johanna, you're on
the air. Hello, hello, how are you? Yes, please
mute discord because we're hearing the Blinkx.
I don't know how to do that, actually.
All right, well, what's on your mind today?
Well, as you see, I'm from Chile. I know you
are close to me in terms of Argentina. Yes,
well, I have a question. This last comment is what
they expect from right wing media, asking those
all those gotcha questions to either just like
you or other members of the cabinet of Joe Biden.
Sorry, you said asking all of those.
What questions? What was the word?
This gut check question, oh,
gotcha questions, yeah,
I think that they're trying to. So here's what's
going on, Johannah. There's a couple of things
going on. One, it's Fox News. So they want to
play gotcha with Democrats. That's what they do.
But especially because Biden just hasn't really
had any cartoonish, big, scandalous missteps.
They're trying to create them. They're
trying to create drama where, let's face it,
Joe Biden's administration has been boring in
the sense that he promised to do vaccines and
we're doing three million vaccines a day. He said
that he would do stimulus and he got it done. He's
just working on stuff. So they're trying to
create drama where there's very little drama.
But I think the dense psyche. Yeah, and
then, well, it's doing a terrific job, she's
doing a good job. I think that she's been
underprepared on some of the immigration
questions where she seems she has some talking
points in front of her, but she doesn't really
deliver them in a coherent way. I think she
could be better on immigration, but otherwise,
I think she's doing a very good job. Yeah.
OK, thanks.
All right, thank you, Johanna from
Chile. Great to hear from you.